Jason Rezaian is a global opinions
writer for The Washington Post.
He previously served as the Post
correspondent in Tehran,
and he was unjustly imprisoned by Iran
for more than a year
until his release in 2016.
And now he's written his opinion
for the newspaper
and it says this I'm Team USA, but
it's more important
that Iran advances in the World
Jason, thanks so much for joinin
Obviously a thought
provoking column there
and you wanted it to be that way
I mean,
this must be
not just what you're thinking,
but what you're feeling at this
Why?
Well, Paula, first of all,
the US and Iran
have not played in the World Cup
since 1998.
That was the only other time
they've faced off in this compet
And for me, throughout my entire
when the U.S.
and Iran would compete
on first and foremost, an Americ
I root for for America.
But this time around, with every
that's happening inside Iran,
the ongoing protests
now in their third month,
the number of people
who've been killed by the regime
the arrests and detentions
of thousands of protesters.
And this is all happening at a t
when there's
so many of the things
going on in the world.
I think it's an important moment
for people to keep eyes on on
what's going on
inside Iran and a spotlight
like the one that the World Cup
is is hard to beat.
I don't
want to put too strong a point o
but do you think that
that could change the course of
and I don't mean on the soccer
or football pitch?
Well, look,
I mean,
I think we're watching history
play out inside Iran
and whether or not
people around the world know abo
that is an indication of just th
of different things
that are grabbing for our attent
You might have seen
during one of the games
earlier on on Monday
that someone ran onto the field
wearing a T-shirt saying Save Uk
And on the back.
Respect Iranian women.
And, you know,
this is a
is a site that literally billion
will witness.
And so,
you know, as history is being ma
in that country,
as we talk about these games,
invariably the geopolitics come
And I think it's just
a really important platform.
You know,
we're talking a lot
about the provocative move
on the part of the US team.
And yet
many are now pointing out
that what the Iranian team membe
did was incredibly courageous by
singing the anthem
during that first game.
And I
found that the coach himself
speaking as a European
and not as an Iranian, obviously
not as much as stake for him.
He basically said it bluntly to
you can not imagine what these y
are going through.
What are they going through?
Jason, you know better than most
Well, it's massive pressure.
You know,
they are the representatives
of their
their country, of their fellow I
At the same time,
their paymasters are a regime
that's brutal and ruthless
and that exerts
a lot of pressure on them.
And your reporting here at CNN
has indicated
that Iranian security agents
have put even more pressure on t
these players to fall in line,
not publicly support protesters,
but just by virtue of standing u
and not singing the anthem
or in a press conference
talking about their support
for the grieving
Iranians who've lost loved ones
in these protests, talking
about how they're standing with
It's incredibly powerful.
It may seem subtle to us
and the outside world
who live in freedom,
but for Iranian standards
over the last 43 years, it's a b
What do you expect to see on the
between the players
and I
don't want to ask you
your opinion on football.
I mean, kind of the way
they will treat each other
and what will ultimately happen
during the match.
Ultimately, I hope that it's
similar to what happened in 1998
which was a great show of sports
friendship.
You know at the end of the day
they're going to be on the field
battling it out
as competitors
But I hope in a fair and friendl
and I expect
as, as an American of Iranian he
and knowing these two countries
really well
and the people of these two coun
really well,
I think that's what's going to h
Jason, I can't thank you enough
not just for your foreign perspe
but a very personal one as well.
Really appreciate it. Thanks, Pa